ah damn that's another file
I'm gonna have to reboot again
[Music]
hey Dwight do you want an Altoid
what do you think
in school we learned about this
scientist who trained dogs to salivate
at the sound of a bell by feeding them
whenever a bell rang
so for the past couple weeks I've been
conducting uh similar experiment
[Music]
okay
hold on sure
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what are you doing
what I don't know
my mouth tastes so bad all of a sudden
tomorrow
[Applause]
foreign
oh
my God
oh yeah oh I knew it I knew it Kevin as
soon as I heard that rapper you really
have to say oh yeah every time you get a
candy bar I can't help it Oscar it's
just really good
oh yeah my hands are tight all right not
bad at all I think we can beat 20
minutes though so let's try again get it
all out now if you have to it was a
raccoon eating a hamburger like a person
you need to stop banging your pen on
your desk or it's gonna drive me insane
okay does anyone have a first aid kit
check out this song I'm gonna love you
downstairs tonight
all right here we go everybody get ready
in three two good luck one
so Phil recruited me to sell these cards
and now I am recruiting you who is this
guy again don't worry about Phil he
drives a Corvette he is doing just fine
okay
calling cards are the wave of the Future
these things sell themselves who uses
calling cards anyway you know what
that's a nice attitude Ryan I'm just
helping you invest in your future my
friend it sounds like a get rich quick
scheme yes thank you you will get rich
quick we all will
continue can you lose a lot of money on
that other investment the one from the
email you know what Toby when the son of
the deposed king of Nigeria emails you
directly asking for help you help his
father ran the freaking country okay
all right so raise your hand if you want
to get rich
all right no um how is this not a
pyramid scheme
again
[Music]
has recruited me and another guy now we
are getting three people each the more
people to get involved the more people
who are investing the more money we're
all gonna make it's not a pyramid scheme
it is a it's not even a scheme per se
it's
I have to go make a call
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
I'm sorry he's not in yet would you like
his voicemail
yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
12 miles an hour
eat that call Lewis
Angela made several 9-1-1 calls about
cars going too fast in front of the
building so the police put up a radar
gun
it's actually caused a bit of a traffic
hazard yeah
wow 13. no no no there was wind I was
just jogging Dwight there was wind I
want a duel I don't know it's not your
turn all right 13 is the new number
Oscar go ahead I want another try here
we go
31. 31. there was the car I was ahead of
the car 31 is my new number 31 is
humanly impossible go Oscar 31's my
number that's impossible beat it hey Jim
Stanley's back from the hospital today
can you sign us
glad they didn't mix up your
tonsillectomy with a mustache ectomy
oh that's not good oh because your jokes
are all hilarious it's nice it's funny
it mentions his tonsillectomy and makes
a funny little joke about his mustache
Stanley doesn't have a mustache
yeah he does Pam hit the brakes Stanley
does not have a mustache
I misspoke
I'm not sure I think he has one now that
I think it has a mustache okay Phyllis
sits across from him every day Phyllis
does he have a mustache or not oh I
don't know oh um now I think he doesn't
Phyllis what are you talking the whole
card depends on this
the man has worked here for 25 years how
can none of us picture his face because
we come here to do our jobs we don't
stick our noses in other people's
business okay which one of these looks
more right neither of those looks like
any person that has ever existed or been
dreamed of in the history of human
Insanity that said the one on the left
guys that's the elevator
what if it's him okay quick who says
mustache
yep who says no mustache
he does help yes
welcome back Stanley no no no no no no
no no no no
no no no no
no okay fine
Ryan
something the matter
Smokey's dead
Smokey the Bear Smokey Robinson Pam he
died like an hour ago I guess I'm the
first to know wow that's terrible I
really liked him oh you liked him that's
nice did you like when he changed the
course of American music like two or
three times did you like the Tracks Of
My Tears is maybe the last true love
song ever written I'm glad you like him
Jim I am completely devastated right now
well my Second That Emotion huh I know a
few of his songs but what were his big
ones oh God Nelly what wasn't his I mean
um Tracks Of My Tears yeah um God so
many Nelly no no no
tracks of my tears and what else what
are some more what's one more
okay I'm not I'm not playing this game
Pam not today I don't think you love
Smokey Robinson I think you're just
doing all of this to prove how deep you
are about music okay I'm sorry that I'm
not a fan of Jason Mraz or the Beatles
you don't like the Beatles that's that's
not the point Eleanor Rigby Paperback
Writer okay you know you always think
you have time to see these Legends
before they go what was I so busy doing
it says who the Smokey Robinson dead
thing is a hoax it's on CNN as of two
minutes ago
okay well that's relief
wow look at that it says he's actually
playing State College it's only three
hours away
oh my God Ryan that's perfect you have
to go tickets are 250 bucks 250 is
nothing to the world's biggest Smokey
Robinson fan
yeah
who's opening
Paul Anka Paul Anka
how can they make the smoke man play
with someone like that I don't think I
can see this okay you can just show up
late though how much is parking like 30
bucks that's not what Smokey would have
wanted does want
Tears of a Clown don't call me a clown
Pam you're better than that
I'm an early bird and I'm a night owl so
I'm wise and I have worms
wow oh breakfast I got your sausage egg
and cheese biscuit yummy yummy thank you
Ryan
what was the thing uh you needed me to
come in early for
um
the sausage egg and cheese biscuit
but thank you and why don't you just
take a couple hours office is yours Home
Alone Risky Business
take your pants off run around
whatever you ought to do
I'm just gonna take a nap in my car till
work starts okay